here's what would happen if earth was  the size of jupiter  on an earth the size of jupiter your  body would be 11 times heavier due to  the higher surface gravity  you wouldn't have the muscle strength to  get up from the couch and even breathing  would be nearly impossible  our new planet would be  1300 times bigger than earth today  this giant earth would pack an  environmental punch  boiling and freezing points would change  significantly and large chunks of ice  like icebergs could melt away  also dropping a huge planet in the  middle of our solar system would have  major consequences this gravity could be  strong enough to pull the moon apart  into teeny tiny pieces this new earth  could potentially even push the  asteroids out of the asteroid belt and  send them to collide with you and you  couldn't even move to get away  so